hey there what's matter uh swim practice
cancelled yeah that's cool is he gonna
sleep in right actually they they kicked
me off the team and took my scholarship
so I'm kind of screwed since my dad's
making me pay my way through school
whatever thanks Jack coming through man
hey we just want to check on you because
we're trying pretty hard in the shower
Frost dogs get in here and help me
polish off this case seeing is that I'm
not even your are anymore actually our
beers from a force oh these are yours
yeah these are ours
sorry well you guys want to make a toast
or something
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I just you know I gotta go
I gotta get going so thanks and goodbye
forever
yeah bye forever bye forever yeah that
guy's gonna kill himself
yeah mm-hmm we're throwing a party what
yeah we're throwing you a massive party
that everybody's gonna come to and we're
gonna make enough money to keep you in
school for now like Van Wilder yeah like
a lot of movies I'm tech yeah all we
need is is peer and drugs and titties
you gots to have some titties baby
[Music]